Yes. Think about the hug. I felt it was pretty good.
It felt staged a little just because it was staged. Um,
and I think that's all I have.
I think that's all the thoughts that I know about it. Well, for me, um,
I did make it a little bit of a joke and try to make a little bit, and,
and I looked at George, he wasn't smoking. So I had software.
He looks better than I used to look. I feel like, huh, nevermind,
sorry, yard. You look great.
You ever done that exercise where you, um,
have you ever done that exercise where you bet where you stare
at a stranger for a whole minute.
I've done that where you stare at a stripper for a whole minute.
Two is a good one. They ask you to leave
work. Is there a window or, or are you in the club or outside there?
In the club. Right, bro. That's the old days though. Yeah.
That's another thing that I'm no longer going to ever do ever again. No,
it was nice. Did you go to a lot of strip clubs? I did. Um,
not since I've been with Khaled,
I've been to maybe two or three sets of about Kalila strip clubs.
Since you've been with me. Oh, in the beginning. You mean problem? And maybe,
I don't know.
I don't remember. Maybe I want, I don't remember.
I don't even remember the last one I went to, but I just assume. Yeah.
I saw two servers of Windex in each other one time
they were next to each other as bodies. They were tightening up. Yeah.
And some of it to have that,
that when you're on the pole to have that the sound right.
I don't go with glitter. If they have glitter on bra. No.
Can you get a lap dance? It's like, it's like a sign. Yeah. Your bus. It's like,
they're like, you know how snow leopards, you know what?
Sloan on a leopard is very elusive. Yeah, no.
Yeah. They are very elusive and there's,
they're barely on camera because they're very hard to find.
Yeah, exactly. But snow leopards, snow leopards.
I think you're talking about the leopard seal. Aggressive,
aggressive.
I was never let's know limbs fall out in the, in Minnesota.
You're not talking about this. That's what I'm talking about. Slow numbers.
Yeah, exactly. I was losing my mind, man.
So snow lepers will not see another snow leopard. Probably their whole life.
Wow. That's how rare they are. But they communicate each other.
Do you know how they communicate bra? Yes. They make different sounds. No.
No dude. You think another snow leopard is like right around the corner,
but they don't see each other. I know Johnny's right behind that Boulder,
but I ain't going, gonna see him just going to go.
What the are you talking about, man? Me dude.
You're the one who's institutionalized.
Come out and learn, man. We're trying to deep.
We're trying to teach him about leprosy bro.
Being fricking to by face or trying to teach your dog. Okay.
Write that down too. By faith. By faith. Write that down to by for Batman.
I'm joking, man. I think you're a beautiful young man, you know,
but it's little leper. Um, very handsome, man.
I think he could be a mayor probably in some cities, different towns,
but in the Island. An Island mayor. Yeah, definitely.
There's a lot of water around the mayor, but yeah.
I don't know if you're a landlock, the leader
and easily run an Island. I appreciate that. Yeah,
man. Snow leopards. The way the communicate, snow leopard.
Are you saying it's leper or leopard?
The, the phone hat. The cat cat. Cat. it. Let's move on from it then,
man. I want to know now you're a snow leopard Bobby. Isn't he? Yes.
He pees out doors and he, and you'll never see anyone else like him.
So how do you communicate with Johnny around the block when you're the snow
leopard? Right?
If I was a snake communication, rare signals.
Hieroglyphs made of urine yet? No, no, no.
I'll tell you what's happening now guys. No,
I don't even know why the I was even saying to you.
You're saying that they, they, they, in their whole lifetime,
they barely come across the.
Exactly what I was saying and how they communicate is they rubbed their sh they
rubbed their bodies on a tree. Oh, right. So then a year later,
another like their mother will smell that tree and go, Oh, Johnny's still alive.
That's cool. And then she'll rub and that's how they that's,
that's her cell phone. You don't have texting, you know, it's more of a Nokia.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Well, you can only do one thing.
It's like a T-Mobile sidekick. Yay.
I never got one of those. I was devastated. I was too poor to get that.
I had one, somebody gave it to me as a gift. One time. It was okay.
It was big though. Big in your pocket.
Do you remember the first Nokia had that one game? Snake love it.
And then when you played snake, you're like I'm in the future. Yeah.
Like you thought it was the most technological thing you've ever seen.
This is future, right? Yeah. I'm trying to think of what, but it was.
It's snake was the best thing. That.
Was a great it's basically what it was. Oh yeah. So you're.
To catch little things without eating your own tail.
So you couldn't touch your own tail. That's what it was.
Taylor. You get longer, right?
You would have to escape, contact from your tail, but still be able to, um,
it was it like a little Pac-Man thing that you would have any,
it would add onto his body. Each time.
It got so bad. My sponsor was like, you can't play snake no more.
That's what it was. Look, I thought that was the future. I'm in blade runner.
Wow. Yeah. Now, you know,
what you can do all kinds of with video games. Yeah. Right.